[Musique]
c'est l'accessoire le plus populaire au
rassemblement du exit c'est aussi le
plus difficile à se procurer en 15
minutes toutes les casquettes mais le
guen ont trouvé preneur ces jeunes
travailleurs du secteur pétrolier m
particulièrement slogan qui rappelle
donald trump aux états unis
sa famille et lui souhaite que le
webzine s'inspire des idées du président
américain
il faut remettre nation au travail
encourager des entreprises locales
plutôt que favoriser les importations de
l'étranger
mais sur quoi exactement se refonder
cette hypothétique nation de l'ouest
[Musique]
pendant que les musiciens et réchauffe
la salle le chef du parti pilot
d'herning nous donne quelques indices
nous on s'inspire du bloc québécois on
veut défendre les intérêts des gens de
l'ouest qui sont des gens honnêtes et
travaillants qui ne veulent pas profiter
de la richesse des autres
en gros si le souverainisme québécois se
réclame d'une langue et d'une culture
distincte
le wpt exit lui est basée sur l'éthique
de travail dit exemplaire des habitants
des prairies pilot downing qui aime bien
d'ailleurs dire à la foule qu'elle est
la meilleure sur terre n'en est pas à sa
première expérience politique
en 2015 il a été candidat pour le parti
de l'héritage chrétien à edmonton
l'ancien soldat âgé de 38 ans a aussi
travaillé comme policier pour la grc
mais il a quitté la gendarmerie
plusieurs années après avoir été reconnu
coupable d'avoir proféré des menaces
contre son ex femme
notre étude en ligne dit le juge s'est
trompé il nie avoir menacé son ex femme
d'ailleurs ils n'aiment pas beaucoup
qu'on évoque cette histoire en entrevue
ce dont il aime parler par contre c'est
de toutes les façons dont les provinces
de l'ouest comme l'alberta pourrait
améliorer leur sort en séparant comment
parce que l'alberta cesserait d'envoyer
de l'argent à ottawa et qu'elle pourrait
enfin exploiter son pétrole comme bon
lui semble c'est aussi ce que pense ce
militant qui devra peut-être se trouver
une nouvelle équipe de acquis si l'ouest
se séparent
c'est
mais les albertains en général sont ils
séduits par les promesses de pilot
d'herning juste à côté du rassemblement
du xixe et il ya ce marché de noël
on est venu demander aux gens ce qu'ils
pensaient de l'idée de la séparation de
l'alberta
non marie aussi nous fait part de ses
inquiétudes
mais comment ce que le webzine va nous
permettre de transporter notre pétrole
plus facilement aux qu il croit que
l'indépendance pourrait être très
coûteuse
même si comme bien des albertains elles
ne se sont pas respectés par le reste du
pays la preuve que la colère ne conduit
pas nécessairement owens et 10
politologue
il faut distinguer le mouvement de
colère et de frustration contre le
gouvernement fédéral contre le québec
compte la colombie-britannique de lits
des séparatistes ou indépendantistes
elle même soit c'est une autre chose
cette idée loin dans sa forme pure et
des certainement plus marginale
d'ailleurs selon un sondage réalisé à la
mi novembre par abacus data à peine 25
pour cent des albertains votre et en
faveur la souveraineté des chiffres qui
ne décourage pas cette mère de famille
proulx exit qui dit se battre non pas
pour elle mais pour ses enfants
si laurence martin radio canada à vrai
dire